Dak Prescott was sedated for 11 whole
hours to get work done to his body that
you would never expect you'd think it
was some type of major surgery not
exactly it was this a massive leg tattoo
and when Cowboys head coach Mike
McCarthy and owner Jerry Jones found out
they obviously weren't super thrilled
that their franchise kubi was put asleep
for half a day so that he could get his
entire leg Inked Up McCarthy's nerves
settled once Zach explained to him that
it was a legitimate operation and that
it was all supervised by medical
professionals so what's this tattoo made
up of anyways it's a tribute to his
mother and brother who died Michael
Jordan Muhammad Ali Kobe Bryant his
hometown in Louisiana and more